here in schloss Mazur berg about an
hour's drive from berlin talks have been
ongoing between shots and Merkel and
President Putin in the government
residence just behind me here a spite
their previous rocky relationship mrs.
Merkel and mr. Putin have been pushed
together into a sort of political
marriage of convenience due to a rift
with the United States both countries
have been affected by US tariffs Russia
has been affected by sanctions mrs.
Merkel has been criticized by Trump for
being overly reliant on Russian gas
import it did have points on which they
did agree Syria being one of the key
ones both of them agreeing that emphasis
on humanitarian assistance was the key
to solving the conflict not a shoe
eternal sisterly issue it's important to
do more for the humanitarian situation
in Syria most importantly bring aid to
its people and help those areas where
refugees can return from abroad
negotiators are anything else for my ed
nurses we have to avoid a humanitarian
catastrophe in Syria there may be less
fighting now but that doesn't mean we
have peace and order Iran nuclear deal
which of course the United States
recently pulled out of was another point
upon which they could agree with mr.
Putin emphasizing the importance of
maintaining that international deal
sanctioned by the United Nations
Security Council
the Nords dream two-part plan project
was also something that was discussed as
the day here draws to a close and the
limousines pull up to take the leaders
back to their residences mrs. Merkel
will take this as an opportunity to
consolidate her position as a European
leader capable of negotiating with
Russia and Putin while the Russian
president will view this as a chance to
take steps to bring Russia out of its
isolation through those sanctions and
find common ground with one of his
oldest political colleagues
you